according to the Reuters news agency  that a spokesman is being quoted by them  as saying that the former Pope Benedict  has died no more information as present  and it's the Reuters news agency that is  reporting this but they are saying that  uh former Pope Benedict has died we were  of course await more information but  just to remind you of course that Pope  Benedict who's 95 years old was the  first leader of the Catholic Church to  stand down in 600 years he did that in  2013 citing Advanced age we can see the  live pictures of the Vatican as Reuters  is reporting that former Pope Benedict  has died  we have heard updates from the current  pope as to the condition of Pope  Benedict in the last few days expressing  concern and asking people to pray for  him